سحب من اتخنه برتقاليه جثمت على السماء
المدينه وتركت شوارعها شبه مظلمه في منتصف
النهار المستقبل الذي تخيله البعض للمدينه
ولغيرها بسبب تغير المناخ بدا امرا واقعا
لعدهم ان ترى المدينه يغشاها الدخان اعمل
في البنايه العاليه وبالكاد اراها لهذا
كلنا قلقون
وكما فعل وباء كورونا دفع الهواء الملوث
كثيرين الى ارتداء الكمامات بتوصيه من
السلطات التي توالت تحذيراتها على مدار
الساعه وخصوصا للفئات التي تعاني من امراض
تنافسيه والمسنين والاطفال
تقديرات تلوث الهواء ارتفعت الى مستوى خطر
ووضع دفع المدينه الى صداره المدن على
مستوى العالم في تلوث الهواء يشعر بصعوبه
في التنفس وبالدخان في عيني وحلقي ولهذا
ارتديت الكمامه
قلقون دائما من هذا لكن بعض الاشياء التي
لا يمكننا التحكم بها دون اشراك الجميع
امور كهذه ستستمر وربما تزداد سوءا
سكان نيويورك اعتادوا على تلوث الهواء
لكنه اليوم اكثر قوه اعتقد انه سيكون مصدر
قلق في المستقبل والسنوات القادمه لان هذا
سيستمر وصحه الناس ستزداد سؤال
لساعات طويله غرقت مدينه نيويورك وسط هذه
الادخنه الكثيفه القادمه من كندا رائحه
الحرائق التي قطعت الاف الكيلومترات في كل
مكان هنا لكن الحياه والاعمال تواصلت في
المدينه وبالايقاع المعتاد ذاته ما عدا
تاثيرات محدوده
مطارات نيويورك الغت بعض الرحلات الجويه
واجلت بعضها لفتره وجيزه كي تتمكن من
التعامل مع الاحوال الجويه السيئه فيما
الغت بعض المدارس الانشطه الخارجيه للطلاب
وقرر البعض الاخر الاغلاق كليا والعوده
الى الفصول الدراسيه الافتراضيه مؤقتا
مراد هاشم الجزيره نيويورك